-The Texas heartbeat bill
has become law,
and now it is illegal to get an
abortion at 6 weeks or later.
Here to talk about it
is Amber Ruffin,
with "Amber's Minute of Fury."
[ Heavy guitars playing ]
♪♪
-Every politician in Texas
wants to be in charge
of my body so bad.
Well, if you gonna be
in charge of my body,
really do it then.
Be in charge of my whole body,
'fro to toes.
Make it all your problem.
I'm lactose intolerant
and I love ice cream,
so every time I want to
have Dairy Queen,
tackle me.
And you better be strong, too,
because I love
a Peanut Buster Parfait.
Tell four-margaritas-in Amber
that she can't have a fifth.
Try and reason with her.
I dare you!
If you want to be in charge,
be in charge.
Manage my calorie intake.
Throw out my candy.
Good luck finding the candy
I have hidden from my husband.
He can't find it,
and he knows me.
And if have the poops --
[Snaps] --
that's on you.
You should have made sure
I didn't eat that food
I knew damn well was too old.
How are you just gonna be in
charge of one part of my body?
What kind of sense
does that make?
Be in charge of
my nappy head of hair.
Find my curl pattern.
Talk me into or out of
getting dreads every 6 months.
I honestly don't know
what to do.
Should I? I can't.
I should. I can't.
And find my goddamn bonnet!
All I'm saying is, if you're in
charge of one region of my body,
what sense does that make?
Just the uterus?
At least take
the whole bottom half.
I want a federally-funded
pedicure.
You can even pick the color.
I can never decide anyway.
Should it be a French pedicure?
I can't.
I should. I can't.
So just make them so
I can wear sandals
without feeling sad.
Can you do that?
Of course you can't,
you dumb [bleep],
so don't take charge of
the biggest decision
I'll ever make in my whole life
when you can't even get me
a goddamn pedicure!
This has been
Amber's Minute of Fury!
[ Heavy guitars playing ]